let's begin with the easy one from img's
perspective what would it mean if Serena
Williams were to complete a calendar
Grand Slam well you said it you know for
us is the most relevant thing that
happened in tennis in so many years I
mean keep in mind that as you said the
last female player to win lancelin was
in 1988 but the last male player to win
a Grand Slam was in 1969 that was Rod
Laver so that will make her together
with the fact that she's going to be the
one who most want most runs slam titles
together with his TV who will make her
the best player in the history of the
game so for us let's player in the
history of tennis yes not just women's
tennis but tennis well you know I think
I think you're right i mean no one in
the in the men's side got that far I
mean row John McEnroe would agree yeah I
mean Roger Federer won 17 grand slam
titles and Serena will be in the 23
reigns so he's huge I mean and you need
to keep in mind that it's tougher and
tougher to win this round slam so to me
it has much more married what she's
doing compared to what stuff you did so
many years ago Fernando why is there so
much attention being paid to the
difference in what Serena Williams as
arguably the greatest tennis player who
ever lived makes and her occasional
opponent and similarly also a client of
IMG Maria Sharapova makes why is there
so much attention um well it's a good
question I mean Maria is is a beautiful
charismatic smart girl she's very
professional and she's very
international you know she's someone who
as you know came from Russia to the
United States and she's been able to
capitalize her success very nicely
Serena though in the recent years I mean
could we say the same things about no
she didn't come from Russia but couldn't
we say all those same things about
Serena Williams absolutely absolutely i
mean the fact that she got this amazing
brands in the recent years like beats by
dre or by JPMorgan Chase Delta I mean
that proves that she's very valuable for
brands
one you rep your company represents her
does she care about this discrepancy
does she talk to IMG about it does she
complain does she say why I don't think
I don't think she cares that much I mean
she focused on winning on the tennis
court that's it and she focused on being
the best player in history but everybody
wants recognition yes there's no better
recognition than the titles and the
prize money that comes with them but the
endorsement money matters it says
something about them how the market and
the public views you yes or not well
again I think she's very well marketed I
mean again if you see the amount of
deals that being produced lately I think
she's very happy with that well she'll
be even more marketable if she wins the
calendar Grand Slam absolutely all right
better than no thank you so very much
nice having you Fernando solare he is
the managing director of IMG tennis some
of his clients on the center stage in
the center court at Arthur Ashe Stadium
this week